hello people of youtube i
am greg john's only friend
how are you john hi grab good how are
you
how's your day going it's okay hey we're
gonna watch superman
lois today man of steel is the name of
this episode
i'm excited to check it out just for
that title alone hey i would really
appreciate it that if you end up
enjoying this video if you could hit
that like button and also subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up or
something just pops up in your feed from
us
you're like you know what i want to
check that out from these guys they seem
like all right dudes
and yeah full length watch along where
you sync up with the time code is over
at our patreon for this show and we
cover a whole bunch of other shows there
a lot of them have the option for
reaction highlights included and i want
to thank everyone who
embarks on this journey with superman
lowe's for us i think this series is
very
underrated i appreciate everyone's
joining our patreon page as well you
guys rock
thank you so much for your support
anywho let's watch
tyler hucklin play superman
every sound will be accompanied by pain
so is man of steel referring to jordan
perhaps
maybe he will emerge anew by the end
those those lead phones i think there's
bows nose can noise canceling yeah made
with
real bits of lead
we'll work on this tomorrow but dad i
still want to play on the football team
this weekend
oh come on you don't understand anything
but we do know that leslie laura has
power so it's safe to assume that other
people do too
i don't want you doing anything that
makes you feel even remotely unsafe
i just had a thought kyle's gonna get
powers in this show
oh no oh no she loves that morgan edge
because jordan has the stuff going on
with the hearing and jonathan hasn't
made any friends
it doesn't feel fair to give them one
more thing to worry about david
ramsey directed this one
dave david ramsey matt pulling and john
i'm not going to tell you who cool
awesome love david ramsey he's tickled
from air overs
send out a small shipment see who comes
for it a small fragment only
and leslie no more failures
oh you're fired yeah oh sorry i'm just
about to knock
you [ __ ] she looked at her
yeah she's already jealous you can do
this
maybe we should have watched this one
with headphones yeah man
i can feel it i feel right in the center
of my brain
oh god
i would instantly go for a rocket
launcher
can i help you
lois lane hello guy who is not marcus
bridgewater
get ready to tell the truth otherwise
this little team level of ours is done
oh he's getting everything he wanted he
gets to hang out more with lois
what are you thinking about this
same thing as last night trying to take
over the world oh
childhood ruined therapy needed thanks a
lot mom and dad they had a
daughter it's not disgusting though this
is a loving display of
affection yeah i know oh how often does
this happen there goes superman again
[Laughter]
just destroying the city someday i'm
gonna have to do something about this
guy
oh evil oh
what a cool that's a cool shot though
he is cool i mean not cool in context of
the practice you know what i mean
homelander no dude
i want to see that show don't worry zack
snyder's directing that spin off
jesse
[Music]
wow they did such a good job on
capturing that yeah
like on a technical standpoint with
sound design too especially absolutely
everything all right maybe you should
tell me
rising jordan at school today i blame
you
tag jumped him the other day that's why
he had bruises on his face
see he's not he's not such a bad guy
yeah and also
yeah i broke my wrist thanks for asking
really sucks
jonathan
jonathan it's the first kind of aloof
thing he's done
all show i gotta say i don't love the
idea of leaving you alone with him
we'll get used to it cause he's here oh
no
no boy wish me luck
good luck
i can't still think of breaking bad now
because of you
don't shoot a winnebago in the desert
that's what i'm saying
oh welcome back captain how was your
conversation with lois lane
not what he's not recognized that he's
all
[Music]
i need to speak with superman maybe when
we're on a first name basis
just tell your name is lex luthor what
could go wrong
your earth has a lex luthor coincidence
intruder in here yes captain
i managed to capture an image in front
oh
god it just doesn't stop
that's a hospital is he a threat no
he's not important i thought he
what that he knew yeah guess he trusted
superman i'll have chrissy look into it
are they still up ahead
yeah about two miles up and looks like
they've got an escort this is so cool
they're working together
yeah superman and lois
things are going to be ugly if i don't
do something
out of the truck get out of the truck
did you realize
it sounded like you rolled a czarian
what the hell
i just planted
what are you doing i assume the same
thing you want
that's not the same thing we were
following the truck hoping to find out
where it was headed
which now we'll never know since you
decided to go full-on rambo rambo's
never done anything like that
cause that's what edgar's gonna use to
build his army so you believe me now
enough games tell us what you
know oh damn she good
she good sure you know how to hone that
super hearing
she should tutor jordan
i sure showed that locker oh yeah yeah
go for it man maybe you should try
talking to it first
nothing good ever comes from anger no no
no no
jonathan no not seeking what god just
way out of your leave
you're ugly
i guess i'm pretty lucky to have you yes
i've been in small building
to know that you're different than me
if you ever need someone to share that
with
i'm almost here wow you're kind of in a
better league than i thought
this is poor kid just let me start
figuring out how to hone into the sound
just when he starts figuring it out
you want to meet superman it's the only
way to stop this
dad wake up dad reporting on the scene
is lowe's lane they have a weakness it
is a rock from their home planet called
kryptonite
find it so that we can defeat them even
she wears all black
our humanity oh god
do you trust him
[Music]
set up the meat
what a shot yeah that camera man on the
other planet was very good
uh-huh even after lois
hmm that was a bitching suit that was
badass
what were you talking to sarah about
earlier what are you are you spying on
me
i've been covering your ass all day and
now what now you think i'm
i'm trying to move in on your not
girlfriend it's not a denial wow i have
had your back
every time someone has called you dumb
or weird or stupid
or awkward and you're just a terrible
person
don't ever spy on me again
oh i mean
can't play pinky flavor no
luther's by referral says there is no
way he has a son
maybe a cousin damn trunk power would
have to be like 80 years old
to have this 40 year olds
not impressed so you say this guy's been
creeping around smallville
how exactly are you planning on saving
the world by eliminating the threat
you think that threat is morgan edge but
he won't be the main source of
destruction
thing is the prince you had us polar
from a guy who died six years ago it's
john henry irons
give me your keys i need your car gotcha
oh
no
you're the stranger oh
no um
you see carlo you're not the man of
steam
oh i am
stop breaker oh
wow
that looks like it hurt
steel damn
that's a reveal john i think someone's
trying to kill that
what where his name is
john henry i think he's been great oh
man
oh superman is really in trouble
and everyone's
please do that please
jordan please focus please you're wrong
about me
that way that way
made a promise to kill you once i wasn't
able to keep that promise on my
butt
[Music]
damn wow
turn off the lights oh yeah i was gonna
[ __ ]
mess him up too
unleash those powers johnny
i mean if he's not affected by the
lights he must not have kryptonian
that was powered that's true
oh
oh you're going to jail man so your plan
worked
even better than i anticipated lucky you
don't let it i mean do it again
tonight's probably been the most scared
i've ever been in my life
gotta say it's also pretty awesome
they told that pretty sick
and dangerous and absolutely
necessary it will save my life tonight
so i think i owe you a pretty big thank
you
we're getting pizza so we're not gonna
keep secrets from you anymore
none of what we tell you can ever leave
this house is that understood what was
that deal with the guy tonight
oh it's just a tortured soul the
tracking and leaves still glitchy and we
haven't finished the hammer yet and
i still set for lex luthor it doesn't
matter
and then i'm coming right back
up forge the fire strongest steel
i love you in that boat
what anything in this world
[Music]
i promise
this poor guy i'm on his side
i'm gonna be right back
who else is in there oh
i'm sure we'll have plenty of time to
find out
[ __ ] all right dragging the mics over
to talk about superman
and lois episode six
it says john henry irons dead
right that's what it said so i was like
okay i'm pretty sure that is steel but
let's see how this plays out then when
he got the sledgehammer
i was like oh [ __ ]
that's what man of steel meant
there you go man of steel he's just a
guy
but he knows how to work with that steel
it took me some processing though
because i was like wait a minute
that like the the i i i
don't really know steel okay i don't
um i i don't remember what animated one
i don't okay in the comics and then like
in some animated properties they've
touched on how like during the death of
superman
that's when john henry irons comes up
becomes steel
that's about like as much as my
recollection comes to so
i had to do some processing going wait
is he not luther and he's really johnny
irons or
or is the john henry irons is that just
a tribute
thing that they're doing is that just an
easter egg name drop they're doing or is
he really him
so my mind was like racking itself so
it's kind of cool
so i don't know if what they have
plucked
here for the origin or the inclusion of
uh steel is now like part of some comic
run that i am unfamiliar with
it's from the shaquille o'neal motion
picture
what are you talking about that's that's
that's kazam
which i'm the only person who remembers
it being kazam apparently
but that's not relevant uh no i know
you're talking
about i never actually saw that steel
movie
but um yeah that's what i was thinking
of when
that popped up wait a minute
huh is it is the name drops just easter
eggs
yeah or is he really a looting did he
like pull up somebody's id
of uh that he could borrow or whatever
just to throw them off and shove it into
the system technologically or something
like that
yeah yeah yeah so before getting excited
that steel is in this show yeah let's
see how this plays out
yeah and then they go but they they they
go on to confirm that when the
daughter's like
this machine still thinks it's captain
luther you know
so they they covered that in a piece of
dialogue
uh still though a very tense episode and
this was his episode
uh whoever plays him man
parks i think john the memory on look
out
look out the memory on yeah hey everyone
come check out my memory come check out
john's memory
over here just pure rocky balboa
no rocky balboa over here
and david ramsey uh if you guys don't
know
if it's not included in the highlights
when i got so excited to see his
name uh and i'm gonna confirm this
because i'm pretty sure
i want to make sure i'm right about this
uh david ramsey is
uh he plays diggle and um in the
arrowverse the the arrow
show specifically and uh and then it
teases at the end of arrow
he gets a green lantern ring
oh yes right right filling the dead
space it's him okay thank god
oh you know you you gotta you get so
nervous when you're saying the wrong
things
yeah yeah you said the right thing the
internet otherwise you're gonna expose
yourself
said the right phone you said the right
thing no you did good you did good
i appreciate you um yeah but the episode
itself was really good you know
i really loved the i loved
how this was
the heart of this show is the family
drama
and it was cool seeing the whole family
involved in the action
like lois and clark are
investigating together and
then you have uh like jordan and
jonathan
getting in the mix and it was cool that
how jordan is struggling this whole
episode i
love the way that was visually realized
it was so painful
so painful to look at yeah it was like
like a real burden to develop these
powers
yeah and i like that they really spread
that out over the episode and took their
time and gave it
you know a few tries of him attempting
it and not
succeeding and then finally like i
thought they'd really naturally let that
figuring out of how to hone in on you
know certain sounds of breathe
well it seems like his powers what i
thought was cool is that they imbued it
and uh and and the soul of the character
like he can't just focus on the sound of
a ticking clock or the sound of a sink
but you know it's where his heart
belongs like when it came to
um sarah sarah yeah
sarah kyle
i came to sickkyle you know sarah
she like posted on her photo
and then i mean there's one version of
this where you could be a real creep
about it if you wanted to
absolutely i mean there are a lot of
superman powers you could create who's
in my contacts
let me go listen to that let me just
focus
myself on their whereabouts yeah
see uh like that moment but then when
dad's in trouble and how
how that actually i like the way that
that came back with him and jonathan
the car like look what you did earlier
with spying on us you gotta do the same
thing right now but for dad
yeah and this is different so it's okay
now but you know before i was still
pissed about that like i loved the way
they handled the back and forth of them
ultimately culminating with that because
like when they're fighting
it it reads very naturally and very
realistically like the
both the performances but also the
writing of just you know what the
conflicts are between the two of them
and
i mean you know jonathan pushing him at
that one point in the hallway i actually
got me pretty tense i was like i don't
know i don't expect him to snap but you
never know
well i like that jonathan actually had
opportunity to show
that there's always so much this guy can
handle man
yeah and that's the thing is like they
they made the point of having that one
girl be like ah you know acting out of
anger doesn't really get stuff done but
then
like later on with jordan it's like i
don't know it seems like he had a
legit reason to lay that out there to
say it clearly and to you know
at least let him know how upset he is
are you
endorsing anger i love anger i'm i'm i
i'm an angry fellow and i think that
it's good for you
well i think you really are underneath
it all good probably
i think you got a lot of anger one day
john will snap he'll be 45 years old
yeah it was just beats
yeah it's all going to come out
yeah well like reaction back to the
family dynamic
yeah it's like because clark he really
looked like he was
in danger i mean he was in danger
but when it came time to taking
to to uh when he was approaching uh i
gotta wrap my head around different
names
uh john henry irons who's approaching
him
it looked like he was about to murder
the guy right it looked like he was
about to
keep on failing on him at the very least
which i mean if you're superman
it's not long before yes you've killed
the man and then and then lois had to be
there to be
like close yeah exactly
but that was also another great visually
realized moment when his uh
black suit is he's uh through the eyes
of
uh steel he is seeing him in the black
suit
and also those flashbacks to his to to
his earth
were [ __ ] terrifying yeah
just waking up and just being like oh my
god there's a bunch of kryptonians
destroying
my city and i love the way they captured
that too just people looking up and
seeing them
hovering and then just all in unison
they start lasering down buildings like
it i don't know it's very jarring
sometimes the use of news
footage to make things feel more real
can be a gimmicky thing and sometimes
it really works on me and in this case
it really worked on me
my favorite part about all that was lois
uh decided in the middle of kryptonian
terrorism
to go on a roof tv though
you could do this on the ground you
could look up at the destruction she's
not
really safe anywhere like if if clark or
any of those kryptonians
heard her they could just as this
episode proves
they could just zero in but where's that
coming from let's murder her
you know she's giving away our trade
secrets of how to kill us
it's almost as if she knew she was gonna
die
she sacrificed herself so she's like
let's go on her rooftop
and not tell jimmy olsen you know jimmy
olsen was the cameraman he was what i
mean did not tell jimmy olsen that
this is going to lead to our deaths poor
poor jimmy
pour one out for old jim but that
i felt really bad for him here very yeah
i know it's like it's a really
compelling way to to both build up
a a villain or an antagonist
presence but also be to then you know
endure you already to a character with a
lot of history
well i think the is that because it was
starting to you know my mind was going
like
and especially in this episode i was
sold of the until he went to his garage
and started building stuff
which was having me think of steel but i
was i spent so much
time going let's just wait for like a
real
confirmation first you know yeah and
uh don't get ahead of ourselves it's
like get ahead of ourselves this could
just be like easter eggs are inspired by
um but i was thinking like
you know i'm starting to believe this
guy as a as a protagonist
uh in this episode my mind was going
there
and the fact that he is now
affirmed to be steel like well he's
probably going to be a
protagonist in this show or not he's not
going to be a villain i think
unless they're setting up for some kind
of spin-off where he goes back to his
earth and
becomes steel in a new cw's series
but i don't know i mean if they're
building up even just to have him on
as another super presence on the good
side in this
universe i mean i would love that oh
yeah my point being is that
uh i don't know maybe protagonist isn't
the right word i just don't think he
will he'll be a bad guy
yeah yeah yeah his motivations are not
sinister or malevolent
and he will learn through this journey
that this
kal-el is different
and i'm looking forward to that because
i like that actor a lot he brings so
much
weight it just feels so bad for him
mm-hmm he's a poor
guy yeah and his daughter i know
right which is so heartbreaking yeah
like i really loved i liked that they
let i don't know how much of it will
make the video but yeah how much they
let that
montage just breathe of them working
together
building this suit uh and you know the
little character interstitial moments
they got between i feel like especially
lately with some of the movies we've
been seeing there's
a tr you know a lot of badasses with uh
baggage have a daughter
and this was an instance of that where i
was like man i really care for
them together and i hope to maybe see
her again at some point you know
well yeah i mean their their whole thing
was so personal because their mom was
killed and
it's also about saving their planet and
also getting
vengeance you know one because their mom
is or her mom is
you know because of the lowest
connection there it also
adds that extra weight of attachment for
at least me as a viewer because then
it's like yeah you have this weird
venn diagram due to multiverses and
stuff
oh dude can you imagine how cool it
would be what an
arc it would be if he gets like the
full-on steel outfit with the
s logo whoa he gets the steel outfit
that would be gnarly and then at the
very end when he and clark make
peace with each other then he dons this
yeah cool let me see that would be
wicked
and then kyle shows up and he's like
where's my fire truck suit
give me one because then he's finally
going to hate morgan edge by the end of
the day no
kyle no smile they just did it kyle
they were like kyle man he might want
this crazy ass jaw
i guess we're not giving kyle the job
poor emily i don't think we could have
handled it on screen from him though
because if he found out morgan had
passed him over like
that character's gonna just have a
complete breakdown there's not enough
time in the episode
i know right now go right back into
drinking yeah
and just go right back out to barbecuing
and drinking a beer
getting mad always shows up you know
it's about morgan edge
yeah yeah good stuff solid episode great
a material
great family drama it felt different
than the other ones you know yeah like i
don't know i feel like like
dramatic yeah it felt like of
a different count not to slag what like
the caliber of a cwu superhero show is
but i felt like yeah i was some
watching something like weightier in a
way or something i don't know more
cable you know well the last one was
like intense
uh and exciting and emotional and this
was like
watching a dark dark drama yeah
it was like watching when the hunger
games
movies were good yeah remember way back
way back in the four times when the
first two were pretty good
hello babe damn that sucks man yeah
yeah and then um yeah then you got
freaking morgan edge being his cliche
self yeah oh no he's so charming though
you better hope for your sake i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do he's
gotta
he could laser you but he's gotta have
something up his sleeve though right
of course he's gotta have something
where he can he's got a special switch
he can flip and debilitate there's slows
off for somebody
yeah there has to be something
especially going to threaten her
and especially she's the only successful
experiment like
what are we going to do what is your
position you better hope for yourself
what are you going to do buddy yeah i
wonder what he has
maybe he's got his own suit or something
well this was a really good episode this
is really solid
and um they're talking about the secrets
being out there i'm like
you mean just just a couple of facts
about this luther or
john henry i feel like we're talking
about it
like the biggest secrets are out there
dad is superman we might be
getting powers at some point uh you know
dod
connections are awkward yeah
yeah grandpa has issues with me yeah
he doesn't want me to tell you this
stuff but i guess we're doing it
love lana she's great who plays her
emmanuel
shrikwee shri qui
who she is she's in i know her from you
don't mess with the zohan oh
yeah she's the romantic lead and you
don't mess with the zone
yeah she is yeah
very special mm-hmm
and i've been pronouncing your name
wrong for years
all this time
all right guys well the day is done
it's time to edit now
you want to help us thanks for being
here let
everyone know about this show because it
is under
rated get out go get
i knew how to do it in the moment but
now i don't know how did he say it which
is
the truck yeah whatever get out of the
truck
yeah and it was perfect because he did
the same way both get out of the truck
because when he did the first time i was
like was that and then the second time
in the u.s and i was like definitely
yeah
it's so crisp though just a glitch in
our editing in our matrix
we'll see you guys on um
[Music]
do